and now six everyday actions and why we
do them
the handshake dates back as far as the
fourth century BC it was a gesture of
peace because it proved the hand held no
weapon which was awkward the high-five
the exact origin of the high-five is
hard to come down did baseball stars
Dusty Baker and Glen Burke of the LA
Dodgers do it first or did it happen a
year later between Wiley Brown and
Derrick Smith either way
they look a lot cooler than these
jerkwads toasting popular myth tells us
people clink glasses to prove that they
hadn't poisoned each other the clinking
caused the content of the glasses to
spill over causing you to drink your own
poison that was wrong it actually stems
from the fact people once drank from a
communal bowl but they still wanted to
retain the sense of unity so toasting
and drinking at the same time was
introduced saying bless you after
someone sneezes has been around since at
least 150 AD when it was referred to an
ancient Roman novel the Golden Ass back
then people believed your soul escaped
when you sneezed and saying bless you
was a way to shield it from evil
clapping clapping to signify approval
probably originating in ancient Rome
plays written by Plautus and Terrance
included the word plot ight which meant
that the audience should clap at that
point in the play thumbs up the thumbs
up did not originate from gladiators in
ancient Rome take that Ridley Scott but
rather from the Old English saying is my
thumb on it the phrase was used to seal
a deal and involve two people wetting
their thumbs and pressing them together
which is seriously gross you guys
take that Ridley Scott